[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIRAJ RAVAL: Hello, world.
It's Siraj, and I teach people
AI on my YouTube channel.
I started learning
in college when
I went to Columbia University.
And when I worked
in the robotics lab,
seeing robots actually move in
real life got me really hyped,
and I wanted to understand
exactly how they worked.
Since then, I've lived
in San Francisco, worked
in the industry for a few
years at a couple of jobs,
traveled around the world.
It's been a pretty wild ride.
I've had the opportunity to
speak at some amazing events
across the world, from the
United Nations to CERN.
I'm really excited
to attend Google
I/O, because a lot
of really cool people
are going to be
there, and I think
it's going to be a
great opportunity
to meet other people
interested in the same field.
I hope to see you there.